any Potterheads will tell you that you
missed a lot of things if you didn't
read the books this is why we want to
encourage you to run to the library by
giving you an idea of what truly
happened make sure you watch this whole
video to know how the story really ended
if you love Harry Potter as much as we
do don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you ten differences between
the Harry Potter movies and books skew
anyone who read Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire remembers view the
Society for the promotion of elfish
welfare Hermione was shocked by what
people did to those poor house elves and
wanted a better treatment for them this
is why she becomes an activist even
though no one was interested in her
project not even Harry and Ron this is
how we got the chance to see Dobby who
was working in Hogwarts kitchen he
wasn't treated like a slave anymore
Dumbledore offered to pay him even
though Dobby didn't want that much money
we also met her friend Winkie a female
house self from the Crouch family who
wasn't really happy to have been freed
she fell into a depression and started
drinking heavily she was also the only
one who helps Barty Crouch jr. escaped
prison convinced that all the elves
wanted to be freed hermione started
knitting socks and hats she left them in
the common room hoping that they would
find them and be free but the house
elves didn't want to go in the common
room anymore
so Dobby decided to keep everything even
those few was not really necessary in
the fourth movie it did become important
in Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
that's because Hermione decided to kiss
Ron when he showed that he cared for the
house elves they didn't just kiss
randomly in the books the challenges if
you watched Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone you probably
remember that the three friends had to
go through a couple of challenges to
find the philosopher's stone they had to
go through a trapdoor guarded by a
three-headed dog escaped the devil snare
catch a key using a broomstick play a
chess game and finally find the mirror
of Erised ed every teacher decided to
work on something to stop anyone who
would be interested in the stone but it
didn't really work when you think that
the first years were able to do it it
was the opportunity for the three kids
to show what they could do and while Ron
showed bravery when he sacrificed
himself we didn't really get the chance
to see what Hermione could do to show
how smart she is that's because two
challenges were missing after all we
know that JK Rowling loves the number
seven so it totally makes sense that
there are seven tasks the sixth task was
fighting a mountain troll like they
already did in the bathroom but Quirrell
already took care of him on his way to
find the stone
so the two kids didn't have to care
about that but the seventh task was more
interesting Hermione had to solve a
logical riddle set by Severus Snape
there were seven bottles of different
shapes and sizes in the center of the
room and she had to use the clues to
find the one that they needed
Rita's Eaters secret you all remember
Rita Skeeter don't you when we met her
and Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
she was a journalist for The Daily
Prophet who specialized on writing
stories based on false information and
misreported interviews when Harry was
participating in the Triwizard
Tournament she decided to interview him
and came up with a story that was far
from the truth she portrayed him as a
tragic hero who cried himself to sleep
she also said that he had a romantic
relationship with Hermione Granger at
one point Dumbledore decided to ban her
from the castle but she still found her
way there she interviewed Hagrid and
asked him many questions that made him
uncomfortable when she met the golden
trio at Hogg's means she also wrote a
story about that devious miss Granger
and later said that Harry was disturbed
and dangerous you might be wondering how
she was able to find all this
information and this is why reading the
books became really important Rita had a
little secret a tiny big secret she was
actually an animagus as she learned how
to turn into a Beatle and had the
ability to spy on anyone to write her
articles as she was an unregistered
animagus she could have been sent to
Azkaban for this
Hermione captured her and threatened to
report her to the authorities if she
kept writing stuff like that this is why
Rita stopped working for the Daily
Prophet for a moment the deathday party
just because you are dead doesn't mean
that you can't celebrate since they are
not alive ghosts don't celebrate the day
of their birth they celebrate the day of
their death that was the case for nearly
headless Nick in Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets for his 500th
birthday and it happened to be the night
of Halloween Nick invited Harry and his
two friends to join in with all the
other ghosts and they instantly
regretted it there was a candlelit
dinner of rancid moldy food with a smell
that would cause anyone to gag that's
because it was so disgusting that the
ghosts could almost taste it
what they called music sounded like a
thousand fingernails on an enormous
blackboard no matter what Sir Nicholas
was really proud to see the three young
wizards at his death Day party because
they made him look good in front of the
other ghosts he even wanted Harry to
tell Sir Patrick that sir Nicholas was
very frightening and impressive that's
because nearly headless Nick had been
rejected from the headless hunt and he
wanted to prove that he was better
without them unfortunately it didn't end
well when Sir Patrick stole his show and
humiliated Sir Nicholas feeling
uncomfortable the golden trio simply
left the room just like Hermione we
would have been really key
is to see the scene in the movie peds
the poltergeist we do love Sir Nicholas
but there is another character that we
would have liked to see in the movies he
appeared in every book so we can't
believe that the filmmakers forgot about
him it is peeves the poltergeist
unlike ghosts a poltergeist is not a
dead person but an indestructible spirit
of chaos that haunts one specific
location at a time generally those where
you can find a lot of teenagers they are
usually not as strong as peas but with
so many magic teenagers in Hogwarts he
became the most notorious and
troublesome poltergeist in British
history he didn't mind pulling pranks on
any of the students or the teachers
Argus Filch hated him and the only
people he respected were Dumbledore the
bloody baron and the Weasley twins even
though he wasn't necessary to the story
he did add a lot of comic relief we did
have the chance to see him in the video
games but why doesn't he appear in the
movies
Rik mile an English comedian was
actually supposed to play pedes the
poltergeists in the film adaptation of
Harry Potter in the philosophy stone
unfortunately they cut his scenes and
weren't able to shoot them again so they
just forgot about this idea it wasn't
even included in the deleted scenes on
the DVD which is a shame anyone who read
the books felt like there was something
missing in the movies when they couldn't
find Kives anywhere Dobby
so we do know Dobby but did you know
what happened to him between Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets and
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
after being freed Dobby struggled to
find paid work that was until he met
Dumbledore who offered him ten galleons
a week in weekend's off to work in the
kitchen but Dobby thought that it was
too much so he asked for one galley in a
week and one day a month off this is
also where he met Winky who wasn't happy
to be a free elf and became a heavy
drinker he frequently used the Room of
Requirement to help her and this is why
he was able to tell Harry where that
room was and Harry Potter and the order
of the Phoenix he also warned his friend
that the inquisitorial squad was coming
before the attack in the fourth book he
is actually the one who gave gillyweed
to Harry and not Neville like we saw in
the movie then and Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince Harry asked Dobby to
spy on Draco and find out what he was
doing he always said that it was an
honor to work for Harry and he was
pleased to do that even if he was a free
elf this is how Dobby had been a friend
to Harry over so many years it makes his
death much more meaningful than what we
saw in the movie the final goodbye
we know that the Dursleys have always
been horrible to Harry petunia and
Vernon treated him like a slave for
years and Dudley always found an
opportunity to bullion Professor
McGonagall even described them as the
worst muggles she had ever seen
this is why it was not a surprise that
they made him sleep under the stairs and
pretended that his parents simply passed
away in a car accident they tried to
keep Harry from being different in any
way but they weren't able to keep him
from going to Hogwarts for he was
finally happy unfortunately when he came
back home for the summer every year
Harry was forced to live in this family
and suffer for a couple of months in the
movies the Dursleys always stay the
worst muggles we have ever seen however
things did get a little bit better in
the books when the Dursleys had to leave
their home dudley actually showed a sign
of remorse when he shook Harry's hand
thanked him for saving his life and said
goodbye
that was after Harry saved him from the
Dementors attack which truly transformed
Dudley in the best way later in life we
also learned that Dudley got married and
had two kids who got the chance to meet
Harry's kids we almost got the chance to
see the last goodbye and Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows but that scene
was deleted from the movies
Dumbledore's backstory if you ever read
the books you learn much more about
Dumbledore's backstory which will become
really important in the next fantastic
beast series it was mentioned in the
movies that he did no Grindelwald but
there is so much more that you would
need to know about them he met
Grindelwald after graduating from
Hogwarts the two became fascinated by
wizard domination which they thought was
for the greater good and went looking
for the Deathly Hallows JK Rowling even
revealed that Albus was in love with his
friend who was soon going to become one
of the darkest wizards of his time there
was also his younger sister Ariana who
was left mentally ill and emotionally
scarred after being attacked by a group
of muggle boys who witnessed her magical
powers since that day she had never been
the same and had even been described as
destructive and explosive because of
this
Dumbledore's father attacked the muggle
boys and was sent to Azkaban while their
mom passed away in an accident many
people think that ariana used to be an
obscure eel like the one we saw in
fantastic beasts and where to find them
she passed away in a fight involving
Albus and Grindelwald and the great
wizard always felt responsible for this
tragedy he then went on to stop his
dearest friend who had become one of the
darkest wizards of all time this is also
what gives you an idea of what
Dumbledore saw in the mirror of Eris at
this whole family finally happy and
reunited James's backstory there are
also a lot of things that you should
know about James Potter Harry's father
was not as nice as you might think
and that's probably why most people
didn't like to talk about him we did
know that he used to bully Snape when we
look back at his memories as an only
child who grew up in a pureblood family
it was no surprise that he became proud
arrogant and boastful he didn't mind hex
innocent students just because he had
the power to do so and his favorite
victim was snake the two guys hated each
other since the first day they met and
they worked hard to make that rivalry
intense and permanent even though he was
a clever student in Hogwarts
he was always mischievous and caused a
lot of trouble to stay with his friend
who was a werewolf he even spent three
years trying to become an animagus
and by the way the penalty for failing
to register as an animagus is to be sent
straight to Azkaban
with the help of his friends James also
created the Marauders map which can do
as much good as it can do wrongs no
matter what there was a reason why Lupin
and Sirius always said that he was a
good man there are not a lot of people
who would have been ready to face
Voldemort without a wand so we can say
that James was forgiven after that the
ending if you read the books you were
probably surprised to see that the
filmmakers didn't listen to JK Rowling
and Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
we all know that Voldemort has always
been afraid of death and this is why he
created a bunch of Horcruxes and facing
his greatest fear was presented in a
much better way in the book Harry wanted
to show Voldemort that he was only a
human this is why when Harry won the
battle Tom Riddle just fell flat on the
ground like a normal human being however
slowly disintegrating in the movie made
him look less human than he really was
what Harry did with the Elder Wand was
also really important in the books the
boy who lived actually used the Elder
Wand to repair his own wand then he
placed the most powerful wand in the
world back in Dumbledore's tomb where it
belongs many fans were shocked at the
end of the movie because Harry simply
decided to break the Elder Wand in two
instead however we do have to admit that
we prefer this because no one will be
able to use it again it would have been
too easy to steal the wand from
double-doors tomb as Voldemort did
before and you do you prefer the books
through the movies don't be shy to
answer in the comment section down below
we'd love to hear what you think and
that's it for 10 differences between the
harry potter movies and books for more
stories like this make sure you watch
this is how the cast of Harry Potter
should have really looked thanks for
watching and see you next time